WASHINGTON WHERE THEFOR THG.Y CH
F WRECKAGE, FLATTENES AND CARS
THAT WERE SIMP TOSSED AROUNDAFT3
UC ACROSX STATESTHIS WEEKEND, K
MISSOURIMISSISSIPPI,.
DOZENS ARE FEARED DEAD AND
CIRN THE NR WILL  RISE AS
RESCUERSONT
ROIO
JOINING ME FROTHCOMMONWEALTH HAT
HAN KENTUCKY?RNOR ANDYRN CONFIRU
HOW NY OYO CACCOUNTE
>> WELL,HEN
PROCESS IS
I CALLM REPORTS THI'VE RECEIVEDS
TO EXCEIS IS THE O
EVENT E  HAD, K
ONE OF THES L LIESO EVENT IN.S.
THE GROUND OVER 22
JAKE, WERE IN . TE GONE
H IT IN
STANDING.
BEPEOPLEEEIT GOES  1KS.
ITU O CHECK  PEOPLE AND  DOORS
THE QUESTION IS SOMEBODY
SANDS
THOUSAND
>> MEAN WHILE E
.
ARSC GOI>>OT OHELP, AN E OF GOO
THAT HAVE COME IN FROMNSWHND SW
RTE F, COAST GUARD AND OE
ALSO HELPING BUT I
MASSIVE, WIDESPR M
RESCUE EFFORTS AGE.
IF WE HAVEN'T FOUND SOMEBODY B
HARDEST, A THAT WAS HIT TH
YESTERDAY, WILL BE
TOCANDLEACTORY I BE IF WE PUELFT
IT'S N 1 DEEP OFN  WHERE
WA.T OUUEHERE ARE
INCREDLE.H THE
E  OCCURTHEMSELVES IN DANGER T L
I WAS  EMERGEN  NI
ENG
IESANS COMING MOMENT BMOMENT,
TRAPPEINT BEE
THEIR HOUSE  GONE, GETTING
PEO THEMST OF
AMAZING EFFORTS.
I'LL JUST SAY INAWSPRINGS,
AGAIN, WHEREFAF ABOUT 2,700,
UNTED FOR WAS GES NG SPACE.
PRETTY
THE LIKELONRTUL
FACTORY.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW WHETHER THOSE
S D
SAFETY OR N E?ISD HAVE A PLA
FACIE BELIEVE MOST RS GOT TO WH
E
SEE THMAHAT TH WHEN
THE AREA, I'M NOT SUREHEPLAN TH
WE'R AND NOT SURG 40TH
I PRAY FORT.
INCREDIBL
MIRACLE AND SINCE 30MORNINWE FO.
F KENTUCKY.GOVERNORESARWITH YOU
TOUCET
ANYT Y
FEDERAL GOVERNMEHA
HELP SHI LIGATAT, ONE WAY  CAN ,
.GOV, TE
ST R
MANAD
TIO FAMILIED
IMPACTED IN WEERPENSE IS LIKELA
LE.THROUGH IT TOGR RED.BREBUD.N
'R, WESTEOPLE. GOVERNOR BESH Y U
WILL VISITREAS AFF THEAND PLED
SUIVORING MEA ADMINISTRA
DEANNE CL.
THANKS FNING
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE STILL
STATE TORNADOES
>> PRAYERS GO OUT TO EVERYBODY
WE HAVE REPOOFE THAT
ARE MISSING AND D FOR.
N'T HAVE NRS
THAT MIGHT BAPSTAININGPRIORI AT
>> IT'S L
NOT JUST R
THERE'S STILL HOPE.
WE SENE OF OUR FAL URBAN
SEARCH AND RESCUE TEAM
KENTUCKY, EY
THE DAY
ONGOIN
THERE IS STILL HOPE.WE SHOULCOE
HAT ARE THE ATE'S BIGGEST PRIOR?
O THEY NMOST? THE BIGGEST ARE L-
IGHT NOW WE HAVE
SO MED AS A
RESULT OF THESE TORNADELRIGOIN
TO NEED TO TAK
MY EXPERIENCE AS AN EMERGENCY
MAR  PEOPL
STAY WH S AND FAMILYHAT NEED SH.
I RESIDENT OF ERICAN RED CROSS
SHELTERING AND WRENUING
TH THE STATES ON NEEDS.>> THE G
CALLE MOST DEVASTORNADO EVENT I
HOW UNUSUAL IS IT TO SEE
THIS POWERFUL TH LE IN THE
YEAR IT'S  USUAL.
WE DE TORNADOES  DECEMBER,
THAT PART IS NOTNU BUT ATHIS MA
WE'VSES LATEN  ALSTHIS T YEAR.
F TIME
SCIENTISTS WA EXTREME E
HAPPEN MORE FREQUENTLYTHNTINUESR
NOTS
SEEING FROM CLIMATE  ARE
THE CR OR GENERATION
WE'RE NG O WITUNITIEE
IMPACTS SEVERE WEATHERS AND
TO DEVELOP SM